bueno son varias cosas muy bueno primero
hay que esperar el resultado oficial
evidentemente pero estos datos que
tenemos ya nos muestra una tendencia
bastante clara y probablemente
irreversible del triunfo en primera
vuelta lo que llama la atención es la
distancia entre los datos que tenían las
encuestas que era aproximadamente 30 por
ciento para el más y este dato que ya es
mucho más contundente sin embargo porque
explica este retorno yo creo que en
realidad el modelo del político del
movimiento al socialismo no se agotó lo
que se agotó en realidad fue esta forma
de gestión política que imprimió el ex
presidente morales a sus últimos años de
gobierno y que el cuyo hecho más
importante fue esta esta manipulación
estas irregularidades en el acto
electoral lo que ahora tenemos es más
bien yo creo un ordenamiento del
escenario político las autoridades
tendrán finalmente legalidad y
legitimidad y otro elemento que explica
está este este giro en el voto este esta
recuperación digamos del proyecto del
movimiento al socialismo como
organización el son los
casi 11 años de perdón 11 meses de
gobierno interino un gobierno que no
solo fue golpeado por la pandemia sino
además bueno fue un gobierno bastante
inconsistente entonces eso es
significado también una reacción de la
población frente a esa posibilidad del
retorno de ciertos pares a teresa y
perdón sino la interrumpo porque no
quiero que se me quede por fuera una
pregunta muy importante y es que cuáles
eran los principales desafíos para este
gobierno le pido que sea lo más breve
posible claro que sí el principal
desafío va a ser
enfrentar las urgencias sanitarias y
económicas del país otro desafío
importante va a ser la necesidad de
generar acuerdos políticos en un
escenario donde ellos tienen una mayoría
absolutamente importante quizás ha sido
una señal una enseñanza en la democracia
mostrarles que aquí por el camino de los
acuerdos y no por el camino de la
imposición y finalmente otro desafío
importante va a ser evidentemente una
recomposición del propio movimiento al
socialismo una democratización de sus
estructuras y una renovación
como organización social maria tereza
buen dia gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 gracias por su
tiempo